hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be a fun tag video for Game of
Thrones I found a bunch of questions
there'll be 15 of them normally I'd be
posting this on Sunday but I'm gonna
start roping off Sundays for Walking
Dead videos so I'll give you guys
updates on the schedule at the end of
this video also since this is a tag
video I'll be tagging some of you guys
at the end of it so be prepared so
starting with number one favorite
one-off episode from any season so just
picking I'd say red wedding hands-down I
think it still beats the purple wedding
along with Blackwater in terms of
moments of shock and awe at the time it
aired I knew what the story was like I'd
read book three but it had been so long
that I just wasn't thinking about it
that much before it happened
I'd also only just started to make
videos so I wasn't like super dialed in
too spoilery behind the scenes stuff
either even right up to the episode I
wasn't even thinking red wedding even
though the name was rains of castamere
unless you were really thinking hard
about it you know like really thinking
deep you probably weren't thinking red
wedding but just the whole way the
episode came together in terms of pacing
the set design and oh god the music I
mean it was just perfect in my mind
probably the most perfect moment of
television of that entire year by the
time season 4 rolled around like I was
completely dialed into the behind the
scenes stuff so there really were no
surprises with the exception of that
white Walker have seen in episode 4 that
was really like the only big surprise on
to question number 2 favorite villain so
technically obviously there are no
villains on the show but I think
hands-down the biggest best villain of
season 4 was at least the mountain the
books do give you some more background
as to possible reasons he might be such
a mean person but on the show
he's clearly painted as a monster and if
you weren't sure before squishing a
beloved characters head like a grape
will rocket you to the top of the
villain list question number three Lee's
favorite main character I would say Shay
just because she wasn't a main character
in the books and there was a really good
reason for that
like she's not meant to be a main
character the show tried to turned her
into something more but I felt like
Peter Dinklage could have just talked to
himself and it would have been more
enjoyable part of the reason why I think
that they jumped her up to main cast was
because they gave Tyrion so many extra
scenes and they wanted to paint him as
being very sympathetic and they felt
like shade did that Peter Dinklage is
amazing all by himself so I don't think
it was necessary and the issue ended up
itself pretty nicely at the end of
season 4 anyway so no more need to worry
about that but on to question number
four favorite sidekick always always
Podrick he's gonna be the hands-down the
best sidekick the series ever has just
like Shay his show version of the
character has gotten a lot more scenes
but I feel like it's been much more
enjoyable just because of the pairings
they've made I'm totally loving the Bree
and Podrick scenes right now I like them
more together as a pair then when
Podrick was with Tyrion they just work
better together both the characters want
nothing more than to become Knights like
Podrick job technically is Squire just
to be clear though I do not ship them in
any form or way he's just there for a
comedic value that's why he wasn't
around
whenever the big fight with the Hound
was going on on to question number five
which character do you love to hate
that's it the only person that I enjoy
hating is Ramsay Bolton he's written
that way but the actor who plays him
takes it to this crazy place where you
actually do have fun wanting him to die
in a very horrible way before Ramsey
came along I would say it would have
been Joffrey but we got so much Joffrey
rammed down our throats I feel like it
got to be a little too much it'd have to
be a little too self-aware like we were
just waiting for him to go away
I think we're getting just the right
amount of Ramsay you know everything in
moderation even torturing Theon if I
were making this video couple years ago
at the end of season two I would say
that Theon was probably the character
that I'd love to hate but under question
number six favorite friendship I would
say my favorite friendship that's just
just genuine friendship there's no like
subtextual relationship going on is John
and Sam well I'm sure there's some sort
of tumblr ship dedicated to them out
there but they feel like they have this
very familiar camaraderie where they
both completely understand each other
and they know what their relationship is
all about just helping each other
survive Brienne and Jaime would normally
top a list like this but I feel like
their relationship isn't so much about
friendship it's more about implied
romance I guess all that being said
though you could say that the Starks and
their direwolves could be the best
friendships on the show most of them
have been separated so you could take it
either way John well or Die rolls on to
question number seven favorite
friendship that never felt real to you I
would say any friendship that
Littlefinger was a part of he's like the
one person I feel has no friends
I really think inside himself somewhere
he
understands that everyone is just a
piece on the game board for him to move
around the books spell out his feelings
for Catelyn a little more specifically
in a way that the show did not so I do
believe that he left her at one point
like he had genuine emotions for her but
by the time we meet him in the story all
that's become completely twisted if not
for Ramsay Bolton
I would say Littlefinger is one of the
most evil people on the show mostly for
his emotional crimes that he commits but
also for the actual crimes that he
commits if he had his way everything
would just crumble the dust and he'd
laughed because everyone's toys were
broken he's like that little kid that
tries to smash her toys when you're not
looking and be your friend whenever you
turn back around but question number
eight favorite wise guy slash joke
teller easily Tyrion you know bran tells
a lot of jokes but Tyrians humor comes
from this really weird place it's like
he has this nervous laugh that actually
makes him funnier even when he's not
trying to be funny it's like I'm not
laughing because I think my own jokes
are funny like he doesn't laugh at his
own jokes he's laughing because he's
nervous
someone's gonna jump out and kill him at
any moment there's something about
nervous laughter in King's Landing that
just seems so much more funny to me than
actual laughter but on to question
number nine least favorite villain I
would say Littlefinger you know he's
very clearly a villain not in the way
that the mountain is a villain like a
big brute he's a little more insidious I
just feel like I'd have more fun with
the character if Aiden Gillen the actor
didn't do the Batman voice all the time
I get it Littlefinger is like this
mustache twirling villain on the series
but I feel like he could convey that
without doing Batman boys like he could
just speak in a normal voice and it
would still be creepy this is really
just an issue with the show in the books
I control the way he sounds in my
imagination it's the show that takes
that choice away from you so if this
video were like just about the books my
answer probably a little bit different
but this is mostly a show video on to
question number 10 least favorite season
long storyline I would have to say brand
but only just because he totally got
dropped
when I say dropped I just mean in
seasons three and four skipped a lot of
his story I feel like it's a good story
but because it didn't involve face
quashing or naked
the show just didn't really do much with
it brains journey in my mind gives you
this nice and mystical dimension to Song
of Ice and Fire that you don't get from
mello Sandra's perspective
hopefully season five will bring that
out just a little bit more I did see the
girl who played the child of the force
was listed as being in episode 1 so
presumably they're gonna follow up on
the events of the finale
question number alum but under question
number 11 there's actually an
interesting one talked about a character
with a bad story or a bad character arc
so I am a pretty loyal Martin fan so I
don't view there being any bad stories
but since this is mostly talking about
the show obviously sayshe the way her
character ended just made her seem like
such a piece of trash if she was
supposed to be this big main character
Martin would have written her to be a
little more self aware of Tyrians
reasons for pushing her away she was
supposed to be clever but if she was
clever why wouldn't she just wait things
out for a few years overseas till Tyrion
could bring her back we have to remember
in A Song of Ice and Fire it's all about
the long con this is not a short game
question number 12 which character
pisses you off no matter how much you
try to like them
definitely Sam well but he's written to
be that way he's like the Lisa Simpson
of the story he'll probably end up
gaining all the knowledge they need to
defeat the White Walkers you know I
haven't read that far hit like we don't
know wins a winner but presumably he's
one of the smarter characters so if he
doesn't die then he'll probably get the
information they need however because
everyone totally thinks he's a fool no
one is gonna listen to him that's like
the curse of Lisa Simpson you are the
smartest character but no one takes you
seriously and thus no one listens to you
I am really interested to see how
closely the Sam Wells story sticks to
the books in season 5 but question
number 13 plot device that gets used too
much definitely using whorehouse sex
scenes to convey exposition people
started calling its exposition I think
after the first or second season Game of
Thrones was the actual show that coined
the term sex position they haven't done
it quite as much since a little finger
left King's Landing because most of
those scenes happen in his whorehouse
but there still are some of those scenes
it seems like every episode I'm always
kind of wondering when the big explainer
scene is coming and who's gonna be
having sex when they explain it I do
feel like that would be like a really
good edu YouTube channel sex positions
I'll just bookmark that for later but
question number 14 favorite character
death scene definitely Oberyn Martell
vs. the mountain that was just an
amazing fight scene to begin with
Geoffrey's death scene you know was
satisfying but all I could think was
thank god it's finally over oberyn's
character arc in general was just so
much more interesting and it didn't drag
out for too many seasons and honestly
there aren't that many fights on
television where you can say someone
squished someone else's head like a
grape
people get poisoned all the time in
question number 15 last one abandoned or
unanswered plotline that always bugs you
so until we hear otherwise this is
always gonna be Gendry as of right now
he's still rowing his way from
Dragonstone to King's Landing for all we
know there are any number of directions
they can take his character obviously
they're probably gonna change what
happens to him in the books and a lot of
you want him to meet up with Aria again
so I'm not gonna mention a lot of what
happens with all those characters in the
books but if you do want to talk about
in the comments please just use spoiler
tags
whenever you're commenting of all the
characters in season 5 I do feel like
arias storyline is gonna be one of the
arcs that stays closer to the books book
4 specifically if you guys want to read
ahead and you haven't yet okay so this
is a lot of fun but now it's time to tag
some of you guys so I tagged chaos
device drake vagabond bragg princess
toes and simply Maya Beauty so it's okay
if you guys can't make videos for this
just do like a tumblr post and then
tweet the link out and just add my
Twitter name in the handle so it shows
up in my mentions I'm also creating a
poll for our first rewatch episode once
we find an episode and the time that
everyone can watch it we'll give it a
try so there are links for everything in
the description and like I said my
schedule is changing just a little bit
so Game of Thrones videos are either
gonna come on like Thursdays or Fridays
now depending on how everything works
out we'll just see how it goes I just
did a big video where I talk about all
the videos and the TV shows and stuff
I'm gonna be doing this fall so you can
click here to watch that if you haven't
seen it already and you can click here
to learn all about some of the new
characters in season 5 thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you